vous connaissez vous l'histoire de cette
pièce d'échec d'une valeur de 820 000
euros oui vous avez bien entendu acheter
en 1964 par un antiquaire en Écosse pour
seulement 5 livres sterling elle est
restée enfermée dans un tiroir durant 55
ans jusqu'à la mort du propriétaire et
que sa fille par hasard tombent dessus
un triée par son aspect elle demande une
expertise et elle découvre que la pièce
aura été un artefact historique en
ivoire de Morse d'un jeu d'échec datant
du 12e siècle d'une valeur inestimable
elle procède à une vente aux enchères ou
le gardien équivalent d'une tour
aujourd'hui par pour la pocket somme
donc de 820 000 euros pensez à vérifier
vos fonds de tiroirs avant de jeter car
le trésor caché sur l'île de Lewis
compte près de 100 pièces dont toutes
n'ont probablement pas été retrouvés